die phoenix wahlrunde
ich begrüße sie sehr herzlich zu unserer
wahlrunde nach der landtagswahl in
nordrhein-westfalen er letztendlich
stellt sich immer die gleiche frage
drückt das ergebnis nur die stimmung im
land oder auch im bund aus dies gilt für
jede landtagswahl aber ganz besonders
für das größte bundesland wie ein blick
in die geschichte zeigt ich begrüße hier
im studio sehr herzlich an meiner seite
eckart lohse den leiter des
parlamentsbüros der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung hier in berlin
herzlich willkommen und ich begrüße sehr
herzlich stephan andreas casdorff
herausgeber vom tagesspiegel hier aus
berlin herzlich lachen sie herr castorf
sie erinnern sich doch sicherlich an den
22 mai
2005 damals gab es ein erdrutschsieg für
die cdu und das historisch schlechte
ergebnis von 37 1 prozent für die spd
daraufhin das wissen wir alles
geschichte hat schröder neuwahlen im
bund ausgerufen heute verliert die spd
zwar nicht die regierung also den
ministerpräsidenten in der herzkammer
wie sie es immer so schön sagt aber
landet unter 27
prozent historisch anlass ein ähnliches
logisches resultat
jetzt mal noch nicht direkt dem
bundeskanzler scholz abschreiben
natürlich wird er sich dass hinter die
ohren schreiben oder es werden die
kommentatorinnen und kommentatoren tun
denn das hat natürlich auch was mit dem
bundeskanzler zu tun sagen wir mal so
das verhalten im zusammenhang mit der
ukraine bleibt nicht ohne auswirkungen
auf wählerinnen und wähler also die
neben natürlich auch dass es im bund
stattfindet zur kenntnis warum sind die
grünen so stark warum ist der fdp nicht
so stark also das hat schon auch was
damit zu tun und ich erinnere mich die
verteidigungsministerin vor lambrecht
das spielt jetzt auch da alles rein also
wie performt sagt manoj durch die reform
das kabinett und da sitzt an der spitze
einer der auch gerne der chef ist der
allen klar macht ich bin ihr derjenige
der sagen hat und dann muss man sich
sagen lassen dass das ein auch etwas mit
ihm zu tun hat ist das so hat das auch
etwas mit ihm zu tun na ja das glaube
ich schon erzählt ist ja auch jede
landespolitische wahlentscheidung findet
ja ganz normal unter dem einfluss bei
politisch interessiert und auch mal
einigermaßen interessierten menschen die
so interessiert sind dass sie zur wahl
gehen auch unter der
wahrnehmungen der täglichen nachrichten
statt und die sind natürlich dominiert
von dem was gerade in der ukraine
passiert was diese bundesregierung tut
und das ist natürlich sehr sehr viel was
ganz automatisch einwirkung neben
vielleicht den schulpolitischen sehr
persönlichen motiven die man in
nordrhein westfalen hat es wird
wahrscheinlich ein gemisch sein so ganz
genau es ist ja nicht
aufzuklären
letztendlich aber dass diese regierung
wie ich finde zwar viele dinge tut indem
ukraine krieg die von
umfragen gedeckt werden wo die menschen
sagen dass gut das finden wir gut
langsam vorsichtig aber gleichzeitig
dabei nicht eine besonders strahlende
figur macht zumindest der spd teil das
ist auch klar
kommen wir mal zu ursachen und wirkungen
der landtagswahl bis heute eigentlich
verhalten alle von einem kopf an kopf
rennen gesprochen wenn wir jetzt auf das
ergebnis schauen über 35 prozent bei der
cdu und die spd unter 27 prozent was
sind auf den letzten metern passiert ja
es war ja so bei dem was man so über im
laufe des nachmittages gelegentlich hört
erfährt exit polls also so die
allerersten tendenzen da ist ja auch
noch eine ganze weile nicht nach einem
kopf-an-kopf-rennen bei 330 aus aber
zumindest nicht so weit weg wie es dann
war das ist dann eigentlich vor allem im
laufe der letzten zwei drei stunden
offenkundig geworden dass es doch ein
sehr viel größere ausreißer war und die
annahme dass yakuza die
wirklich zieht und die leute eigentlich
ihn lieber haben wollen als den
ministerpräsidenten hat offenbar nicht
funktioniert oder trifft nicht zu der
neuen punkte ist der jetzige stand
abstand zwischen den beiden parteien das
ist wirklich ein kopf-an- deutlich man
sagen brustbein rennen
wir haben gerade letzte woche die wahl
in schleswig-holstein gehabt alle haben
gesagt das war eine landespolitische
themen wieder im vordergrund standen das
war der leuchtenden ministerpräsident
der da
in den köpfen herum schwirrt was war das
bei dieser wahl haben landespolitische
themen eine rolle gespielt wenn man sich
die fdp an guckt ich glaube die
schulpolitik das haben die grünen
übrigens bei der vergangenen wahl erlebt
also die schulpolitik spielt eine große
rolle in nordrhein deutlich und whisky
gut dann ist gut aber ist sie schlecht
dann geht es schlecht aus und die grünen
wehren uns an sylvia löhrmann die hat
die quittung auch bekommen das ist eben
in nordrhein-westfalen richtig schwierig
dann kam noch die korona zeit dazu und
alles was ein crooner dann nicht richtig
lief auch an den schulen wurde an der
fdp an der schule ministerin abgemacht
dass da vielleicht ministerpräsident
erst armin laschet man vergesse nicht
aber lange im amt und dann auch eine
größten rolle gespielt haben könnte das
wurde dann nachher so ein bisschen
verdrängt auch deshalb weil die menschen
gesagt habe mit der fdp wird schwierigen
dann geber der cdu die stimme also es
ist keine leihstimmen kampagne gewesen
sondern dem motto gib mir mal die stimme
damit das bürgerliche lager gestärkt
aber natürlich haben landespolitische
themen rolle spielt nur eines die cdu
hat einen sehr starken einen sehr
starken minister er hat viele sachen
richtig gemacht die leute fühlen sich
bei ihm sicher und das spielt auch eine
rolle ganz am ende die wahlbeteiligung
ist ja schlecht ich hätte fast gesagt
grotte also 56 750 prozent das nachher
58 sein wenn dann die wahlbeteilung
durch die briefwahl vielleicht noch
etwas verbessert worden es ist eine
stadt ist eine schande aber das ist für
ein großes bundesland schon nicht
richtig gut ist überhaupt für die
demokratie richtig schlecht und
das privileg wählen zu dürfen das ist
irgendwie nicht erkannt und
wahrscheinlicher manche auch gesagt ach
mensch tatsächlich da ist bei der spd
auch wir schaffen das nicht so richtig
am anfang wird wir rennen und dann
gucken wir mal das besser wird von 17
immerhin auf 26,9 immerhin aber 26.9
historisch schlecht für die spd nicht
das gesamte bundesland die herzkammer
das war einmal das westliche westfalen
und da fängt schon an das hat franz
müntefering damals als
landesvorsitzender in nrw aufgelöst da
zeigt sich schon was die spd
möglicherweise im verlauf der jahre und
jahrzehnte alles falsch gemacht haben
könnte dieses bundeslandes für die spd
komme gleich noch intensiver
klose erst mal aus zu finden wir es denn
nur der abend überhaupt der wahlsieger
also das können wir jetzt nicht danach
bemessen wer am ende der
ministerpräsident ist aber wenn eine
partei neun punkte vor dem
zweitplatzierten landet also die cdu vor
der spd ist es glaube ich absolut
betrachtet eindeutig der wahlsieger wenn
man es relativ betrachtet sind es
natürlich die grünen das ergebnis zu
verdreifachen
das ist spektakulär ist übrigens auch
eine gewisse herausforderung denn wenn
man dass die zahl der abgeordneten
verdreifacht braucht man auch dreimal so
viele büroleiter mitarbeiter und so
weiter also die müssen jetzt ihren
apparat natürlich in einer rasenden
geschwindigkeit aufpumpen man wird sehen
ob sie das gut hinkriegen aber erst
einmal haben sie offenbar sehr viel
vertrauen von den wählern bekommen
glaube ich übrigens auch dass da eine
gewisse bundespolitische komponente mit
dabei ist weil ja in dieser ampel
regierung vor allen dingen die beiden
grünen minister habe berbalk sehr gute
umfragewerte haben und offenbar einen
hohen beliebtheitsgrad also der absolute
wahnsinn cdu der relative sind die
grünen aber da will ich nochmal
nachhaken mit der cdu immerhin ist
schwarz gelb abgewählt worden das war
die regierung das stimmt aber es gibt ja
auch erkenntnisse dass stimmen von der
fdp zur cdu gegangen sind ich glaube
dass tatsächlich die innere sicherheit
und herbert reul da eine rolle was das
landespolitische angeht gespielt haben
zur schulpolitik noch ganz kurz das ist
natürlich etwas was die menschen
landespolitisch trifft die ukraine die
steuern die rente das wird im fernen
berlin gemacht schulpolitik wird in
düsseldorf gemacht wenn das nicht
funktioniert die menschen haben kinder
oder sind lehrer oder haben geschwister
oder haben irgendwie also so ganz ohne
kontakt zu einer schule sind die
wenigsten und das haut dann rein und da
kann man sich natürlich auch wahnsinnig
darüber aufregen ja wie gesagt das ist
ein thema hendrik wüst ähnlich wie
tobias hans ist in der laufenden
legislaturperiode ins amt gekommen wir
kennen die umstände im gegensatz zu
tobias hans hat er es geschafft ist dass
sein es wird dem armin laschet jetzt so
richtig weh tun da wird ja zu hause
sitzen wir sind noch mal ich hätte jetzt
wieder gewählt werden können außerdem
ist hendrik wüst hat noch besser gewählt
worden also armin laschet beim
vergangenen mal 33 und jetzt hat er fast
36 das ist schon ein unterschied
er hat davon profitiert dass die
mannschaft eingeschworen war das muss
man sagen das hat der armin laschet
geschafft durch diese moderieren eine
art die mannschaft hat funktioniert da
kommt hendrik wüst und der hat sich ja
sehr verändert im vergleich zu früher
auch ein ausgleichender politiker
geworden ja ich habe beim vergangenen
mal gesagt dass also diese slim fit
nicht notwendigerweise überall verfängt
er ist auch erst in slim fit politiker
arbeite er hat das offenkundig herz auf
dem rechten fleck jedenfalls aus sicht
der nordrhein westfälin also wohl der
westfalen also auch der rheinländer und
gerhard jordan macht das doch ordentlich
und dem kann man vertrauen das ist
interessant auch gut die war ja nicht so
bekannt also thomas kutcher hat die
schon der name ist nicht wirklich jedem
bekannt und trotzdem war es so 33
prozent für kutcher hat die 41 nach
kurzer zeit für hendrik wüst irgendwas
ist da nun hat ja auch eine erscheinung
ist erscheint als groß und macht was her
und das ist eben dann doch hat dann doch
auch verfangen und nochmal die
mannschaft waren nicht schlecht und da
liegt auch an der fdp insofern ist sie
unter wert geschlagen die haben schon
auch sich mindestens verdammt noch mal
bemüht anständige regierungspolitik
abzuliefern und manchmal läuft sein
gegen dich und es ist nicht alles der
cdu gegangen sondern ich glaube das hat
wirklich auch was mit dem bund zu tun
die fdp wenn ich das noch sagen liefert
im bund nicht das was ihre klienten
kommen wir doch genau wo die spd grünen
fdp kommt man mal kurz auf armin laschet
ist scheint dann ja schon fast wie
ewigkeiten her aber es war ja nun auch
erst im sommer das letzten jahr aus dass
der wechsel stattfand sprechen wir jetzt
von einem wüsten effekt und wie kommt
das dass armin laschet eigentlich in den
köpfen überhaupt gar nicht mehr
stattfindet hat wüst geschafft dass die
menschen ihn vergessen haben gut würden
findet mit köpfen nicht mehr statt seit
die bundestagswahl im september war und
das gab ja eine spektakuläre niederlage
das heißt warum sollte man sich jetzt so
als normaler wähler zeitung leser und so
weiter noch intensiv mit armin laschet
beschäftigen der dominiert nicht mehr
die deutsche politik auch die
nordrhein-westfälische nicht mehr das
ist einfach dass schäuble diktum zu
gebrauchen ich hoffe all die die andere
frage ist natürlich und da spielt ja
dass der lasche mit rein laschet hatte
den wirklich das problem dass zu seiner
zeit aus einer kandidatur seiner in
seiner zeit als ministerpräsident die
cdu csu die union das war das war ein
schläger kommando also die haben sich am
alles getan und sind eine zu erwecken
beim wähler wir sind uneins wir streiten
uns wir machen ein riesen durcheinander
wüst ist so der erste vielleicht mit
daniel günther die beiden die so richtig
davon profitieren dass wieder ruhe in
der bude ist ja dh sie sind einig und
das ist ja ein uralt lehrsatz ich glaub
ja funktioniert auch weil wir zwei fdp
kommen wenn wir darüber sprechen ruhe
kommt gut an weil niemand der irgendwie
unten zum schiff sitzt will dass der
kapitän und der steuermann da oben
irgendwie mit der mit der flasche
auseinander losgehen das ist jetzt eben
weg und das hat vielleicht tobias hans
der hat davon nicht profitiert dafür war
die wahl im saarland zu früh und jetzt
die beiden wahlen so die voerder später
ist für sich zwar nein ich meine das was
die ruhe in der eu angehen so da war das
so gerade und jährlich das wirklich der
eindruck cdu gehen erzählt er im bund
ihrer wege der märz ist der
oppositionsführer das kann auch ein
bisschen bewirkt haben cdu hat nicht
mehr so negativen beigeschmack ja wir
haben gesehen daniel günther mit
riesenerfolg jetzt sehen wir hendrik
wüst das sind ja also zumindest hendrik
wüst ist jemand der eher so aus der
zweiten reihe gekommen ist wird man die
großen aus nordrhein-westfalen sich so
anschaut da gibt es ja durchaus größeren
namen also friedrich merz ja sowieso
aber röttgen sparen lindemann also es
gibt ja durchaus nordrhein-westfalen
politiker die man vielleicht sogar auf
dem ersten blick eher in dieses amt
hätte bringen müssen aber zieht jetzt
ein herr daniel haben ja sowieso daten
günter meyer ja sowieso schon gesagt
aber zieht jetzt auch ein herr wüst so
an diesen großen allen vorbei jetzt
schon von nachfolgern oder jetzt ist
gerade mal sieben monate im amt
erst einmal wiedergewählt werden
zumindest darin das ist noch nicht
sicher das ist eine voraussetzung und
daher günther hatten vorteile
platzvorteil der hat eine wiederwahl
geschafft nicht nur eine wahl gewonnen
sondern wiederwahl gewonnen und die hat
auch noch gewonnen bei der hat er
gewonnen menschen dazu gewonnen stimmen
dazu gewonnen das musste erst mal
hinkriegen und das ist egal ob sind
schleswig-holstein oder sonst wie es das
musste erst mal schaffen das muss herr
wüst erst noch mal
schaffen dass er überhaupt jetzt
ministerpräsident wird was sie noch
sagen wollte ist zur cdu niemand spricht
er von also der friedrich merz hat
mindestens nicht gestört ich will mal
ganz vorsichtig sagen dass wir auch ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein müssen was die
beurteilung und rudi merz angeht so dass
er so gar nichts damit zu tun weil die
nächste frage werden wir kommen ja noch
dazu würden sie sagen nein also für die
merz hat schon auf was mit dem ganzen zu
tun denn conti nordrhein westfalen das
ja gut aus
hochsauerland ja brilon und so alles gut
das geschenk nein ruhe im beritt klare
linien klare führung das braucht die cdu
das war vielleicht sogar jede partei
aber die cdu in sonderheit die sind das
von früheren zeiten gewohnt wir fanden
das nie so ganz so schlecht wenn es um
mehr an das passiert ja auch eine menge
unsinn und nein das ist es hat
mindestens irgendwie mittelbar was mit
friedrich merz zu tun das heißt nicht
dass der jetzt der größte alle strategen
wäre aber er gibt der partei etwas so
dieses gefühl wir sind doch wer verdammt
aber es funktioniert ja und wenn wir
zusammenhalten und angelo ist ihm sind
und wie gesagt nicht ständig rum
streiten dann macht es läuft ja auch der
generalsekretär
man hört nicht dass der generalsekretär
gegen den vorsitzenden arbeit man hört
lich dass die stellvertretenden
vorsitzenden gegen den vorsitzenden
arbeitet auch schon mal was frau prien
und andere die kommen sogar zur geltung
herr linnemann alles namen die wir uns
merken sollten denn in den kommenden
monaten werden die kommen der friedrich
merz ist kein heuriger hase und die
wahlen jetzt sollten uns lernen dass wir
ihnen mindestens nicht aus den augen
verlieren sollten schon gar im blick auf
die sozialdemokratie die ich kann jetzt
nicht erkennen nicht davon profitiert
dass sie im bund regiert also so ganz
klar hat der gast ob das jetzt nicht
ausgesprochen ob es einen effekt gibt
oder nicht sowohl als auf oder ich das
ist ein bisschen wie bei scholz auf
kommerz
ich weiß eigentlich ob sie wirklich
großen negativ schon defekt gegeben hat
es gibt auf gar keinen fall einen
negativen effekt das haben wir dann
als der aus dem stand nach dem merkel
wirklich weg war mit 94 prozent von 94
prozent der cdu
mitgliedern zum vorsitzenden gewählt
worden ist merkte man wir wollen jetzt
endlich eine führungsfigur wir wollen
ruhe und das hilft also ob das märz ist
weil er so geniale ideen hatten so ein
genialer oppositionsführer ist oder ob
das der märz ist der dafür steht das
jetzt in ruhe berlin gewann er als er
stört hat nicht nähe dass ich glaube
schon er hat also also erstens mal wie
hieß noch mal dabei
haben wir alle schon fast vergessen
markus söder der hat die unions
schlagzeilen über jahre bestimmt der ist
erst mal auf einem unerklärlichen
gründen im moment mal gerade
das heißt märz ist sozusagen unbeschadet
von den schüssen aus dem süden er hat
das hat er den fraktionsvorsitz herrn
brinkhaus in kalter aber erfolgreicher
mann ihr weggenommen er ist die nummer
eins und wir sehen jetzt im bundestag
ist auch wieder geklärt
oppositionsführer ist nicht mehr
alexander gauland oder sonst jemand von
der afg der oppositionsführer ist
friedrich merz und das ist alles
zusammengenommen glaube ich hilft auf
jeden fall der cdu und da in nordrhein
westfalen bekannt ist ohne ironie dafür
dass der so lange weg war es der
operativen politik macht er verdammt
gute oppositionsarbeit nicht wirklich
weg gewesen wäre nun gut dann kann man
sagen er konnte er immer
oppositionspartei weil er praktisch
immer in der opposition war als er in
der aktiven politik will sich gleich an
yann aber mindestens weiß der wie es
geht und das ist für die cdu in ihrer
situation auch schon mal ein erlebnis
also da weiß einer wie das geht und wie
man den bundeskanzler und die
bundesregierung auch mal stellt gibt so
zwei drei sachen nur sie jetzt nicht
alle aus buchstabieren aber zwei drei
sachen im deutschen bundestag wo der
friedrich merz das muss man nicht
sympathisch finden darum geht es auch
wieder nicht aber wo sie gestellt hat
und das ist die aufgabe der opposition
opposition ist nicht mist opposition ist
teil der demokratie und ich erwarte von
ihr dass sie die regierung bei
bestimmten bei wichtigen fragen dazu
bringt bessere politik zu machen als es
vielleicht gewesen wäre wenn sie keinen
anspruch erhoben hätte also insofern hat
natürlich auch getrickst wenn ich
zurückdenke wo er am anfang den eindruck
erweckt hat die unions fraktion macht
das alles mit und dank seiner nähe
machen wir doch lieber nicht und genau
so macht das jetzt mit den 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr das er
also großartig der bundeskanzlerin ihre
rede die sie erhalten haben jetzt gehen
wir meinen details also das macht
ich weiß nicht ob sich unsere
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern noch hans
jochen vogel erinnern den ehrenmann der
deutschen politik schätze ich auch sehr
wenn als der oppositionsführer war hat
er ähnlich gearbeitet da zog der dann
plötzlich irgendwelche anträge der
regierungsfraktionen heraus da stand
dann spd drüber und dann müssen wir das
ablehnen natürlich wird so gearbeitet
auch einen deutlich zu machen ihr seid
ihr wir sind wir aber wir haben uns
helfen und dann steht euch aber auch
waren wir wollen dass dafür so dass
jetzt auch nicht vermessen zu sagen wenn
wir euch helfen sollen dann möchten wir
dass da hinten ist der wahlsieg für
hendrik wüst letztendlich auch teuer
erkauft weil das auf kosten der fdp ging
schwarz gelb abgewählt noch ein stich
worden also ich habe auch phoenix eine
kollegen gesehen die gesagt hat also
jetzt mal keine krokodilstränen jeder
kämpft für sich allein du muss die leute
überzeugen mit dem was du da an
personellem und inhaltlich im angebot
hat und da gibt es keine leihstimmen ist
nicht so als ob die leute jetzt kriegst
du mal ausnahmsweise man kann das so
nennen das werden wahrscheinlich alle so
tun und dann wird dass die fdp so reden
aber nein irgendwas hatten nicht
überzeugt irgendwas hat nicht
funktioniert und da muss ich jede partei
die karten selber legen die spd in
irgend auch warum hat das alles nicht
funktioniert das historisch schlechte
ergebnis in ihrem bundesland das ich war
johannes rau andere regiert haben dooley
heinz kühn ja also das ist ja wenn man
sich das vorstellt
so eine art wahlsieg zu reklamieren und
zu sagen ja wir stehen für die
landsregierung verfügung und möchte
eigentlich auch so hat das nicht gesagt
aber den ministerpräsidenten stellen du
lieber gott ja wir kommen jetzt mal zur
zuerst bgr lose also wenn ich hier ein
coach adi richtig verstanden habe vorhin
vor allen dingen gesagt das wahlziel
schwarz-gelb abwählen ist erreicht also
ist ein wahlziel für die spd in dem fall
gerade haben wir ja gehört jeder kämpft
für sich reicht das aus als wahlziel
dass man die regierung ab fehlt gut wenn
ich neun punkte hinten liegen dann habe
ich ja nicht automatisch zehn
möglichkeiten von den feldern wahlzielen
zu sprechen also dieses ist natürlich
wollten die abwählen wie jeder der an
greift den anderen ab wählen will
insofern ist mir jetzt nicht so
aufgefallen dass das deren premium ziel
war an sich ist es ja eher so soziale
gerechtigkeit und so weiter aber gut
dass die das wollen ist klar das ist
geschehen also das kann nicht
funktionieren
und damit hat er natürlich zumindestens
erstens die möglichkeit zu sagen wir
haben was geschafft also die fdp ist ja
nicht so sehr wegen der spd sondern
wahrscheinlich an sich selbst furchtbar
gescheitert und zweitens mal muss man
natürlich wenn ich überhaupt noch
irgendwelche ansprüche habe selber
ministerpräsident zu werden muss ich ja
irgendwas vorweisen können irgendwie
trophäe sie oder nimmt ja also
schwarz-gelb ist abgewählt heißt da
könnte er jetzt noch mehr zu bruch
gegangen sein und dann kommt sie ins
spiel der ja ein bisschen komisch wenn
man neun punkte hinten liegt aber
natürlich ist das rechnerisch möglich
wenn sich die dinge weiter über den
abend zu entwickeln fdp bleibt drin
natürlich kann man die bundesregierung
nachbauen und und mithelfer doch kommen
mag das wenn man so weit hinten liegt
das kommt darauf an also was er zu
bieten hat was die fdp wiederum zu
bieten hat also die vorstellung mit
einer einstimmung mehr mit der cdu das
land relativ ruhig reagiert zu haben wie
die fdp jetzt hat und dann auf einen
schlag so ein tag zu erleben dann ist
man wahrscheinlich relativ beweglich und
das kann man ja auch erklären und sagen
es geht doch gut im bund mit unseren
bildern baum wird so eine ampel in
nordrhein westfalen nach die fdp es
weiter an der macht ja also ich würde es
nicht komplett ausschließen aber die
bundesdeutsche geschichte lehrt dass das
wirklich wirklich selten passiert also
wenn man herrn kutschaty heute abend
zugehört hat dann hatte er vor allen
dingen als großen erfolg verkauft dass
die umfragen ja noch vor gar nicht so
lange bei 17 prozent lagen und jetzt
aber 27 und das ist ja ein ordentlicher
schritt nach vorne ist es vielleicht so
ein bisschen an herrn magath gesagt ja
wir waren ja auf platz 17 mit der hertha
jetzt immer auf platz 16 das super
erfolg
so ein bisschen aber kann man damit dem
4 es ist noch ein bisschen
stimmt also
1726 stimmt also rein rechnerisch und so
ist das alles war zweitens ist ein
bisschen wie im bund also da war die spd
hat vier anläufe genommen den
bundestagswahlkampf zu öffnen wobei 14
15 prozent und landet bei 25
das erinnert ein kleines bisschen daran
man versucht glück dabei aber in diesem
fall reichte es nicht weil da eben herr
wüst war und kein armin laschet in einer
zerstrittenen union an der spitze oder
wir machen das jetzt so zu sagen so ich
also der druck aus berlin wird enorm
groß sein diese ampel wie sagt der
kollegin nachzubauen die werden sagen
das hat ja schon angekündigt wenn rot
grün nicht gehen mit verlaub dass wir
auch in dem dann müssen wir was machen
so israelische das israelische angebot
ich mach zweieinhalb jahre und dann
kommt der eigentliche wahlsieger die
verdreifachten grünen und dann
bitteschön von neumanns zu
ministerpräsident werden irgendwas
müssen die anbieten was wirklich anders
ist und was wirklich groß ist denn das
herz chardy aus sich selbst und aus dem
wahlergebnis heraus das recht hätte
diese regierung anzuführen ist nicht
ersichtlich erinnere auch daran da
müssen ihre eigenen worte auf essen als
die bundestagswahl geschlagen war damals
die drei gesagt naja die wahlgewinner
müssen selbstverständlich und die fdp
die cdu hatte praktisch cdu/csu hatte
praktisch noch nicht mehr die die sagen
wir mal die möglichkeit also ich würde
ihn schon bestritten mit den anderen zu
reden weil die ja die wahl verlierer
waren da gab es ganz klare harte ansagen
die cdu hat er eigentlich das recht
verwirkt hier eine regierung bilden zu
wollen sie liegt aber im bund liegt die
cdu/csu unwesentlich hinter der soziale
hinter der sozialdemokratie und im land
nordrhein westfalen liegt die spd aber
wesentlich hinter der cdu dennoch wird
ich sage ich voraus der druck enorm groß
werden denn nordrhein westfalen ist das
bevölkerungsreichste nicht das größte
aber das bevölkerungsreichste und
industrie stärkste bundesland und wer da
regiert regiert die ich glaube 16
größten industrienationen der welt also
werden die sagen was man auf die setzt
alles daran um notfalls machen wir den
grünen angebot das ist der trend dass
wenn die regierung vorstellen so eine
abwechselnde ministerpräsidentschaft
zwischen
im größten bundesland also ich bin ein
freund originelle ideen und da ist jetzt
eine menge drin an originellen ideen
entscheiden ist natürlich was die grünen
für sich für den beste lösung halten die
grünen sind diejenigen die entscheiden
welche regierung gebildet wenn sie dem
wüst sagen du musst nicht bei uns
klingeln das machen wir nicht das wollen
wir die schwarz grün wollen wir nicht
dann ist der wüste aus auch wenn der
neun punkte vorne die ich dann kann er
natürlich wütende reden halten und sagen
schwer zu erklären so das ist sehr
schwer zu erklären so aber sie könnten
das machen dann sagen sie wir nehmen uns
den wahlverlierer kutschaty und den am
beckenrand stehen der fdp und pressen da
was zusammen damit wir in zwei jahren
also dass heiliges modell oder was auch
immer also wenn man eine wette
abschließen würden müsste ich sagen nee
das wird nix aber halte ich für einzelne
die grünen wollen zu 70 prozent die
grünen auf asphalt eine rot grüne
koalition okay dann nehmen sie fdp noch
mit haben sie die ampel zu 70 prozent
der grünen landesverband ist nicht mona
neubaur original bei der industrie und
die im handel bomben ruf hat die auch
weit ins bürgerliche lager hinein mal
aber zu den grünen das ist schon noch
377 also das reicht nicht heißt die
müssen ein solches angebot machen die
sozialdemokraten dass die tatsächlichen
nicht mehr nein sagen können wir bleiben
noch mal ein bisschen war der spd ackers
oft würde gern noch mal auf kutschaty zu
sprechen kommen ist das nun ein
schwacher spd-kandidat letztendlich
gewesen mit seinen 7 29 prozent oder ist
es mehr so dass man ein stück weit auch
die ampel oder die die spd im bund
abstrafen
da spielt ja alles eine rolle also ich
glaube wenn man durchs land fährt dann
werden nicht viele thomas kutschaty so
wirklich richtig gut kennen sagen der
steht für das und das und das ist nicht
einmal länger zeiten sind jetzt da also
er war mitglied der regierung ja aber
das gilt in allen landesregierung dass
nicht jeder minister gleich bekannt ist
also minister heißt nicht gleich ist
bekannt dass wäre eine gleichung die
nicht immer aufgeht sagen wir mal so
also weiten teilen wird der nicht oder
mindestens nicht als als bekannten
bekannt dafür sein wofür er jetzt genau
brennt das war ja vorhin die geschichte
also wenn jemand sagt ich will dass
schwarz gelb abgewählt wird dann ist das
aus dem negativen
herausragende definition niveau für
willst du wofür willst du die macht
haben und da musste er kommen und sagen
was mal auf und ich führe euch dann in
diese gute zukunft aus folgenden gründen
und das muss mit einer dynamik
verbunden werden da würde ich dann sagen
da ist thomas kutschaty nicht der
kandidat gewesen der jetzt die menschen
im ruhrgebiet anderswo so begeistert
dass sie gesagt haben ihr folgen also
man traute spd auch nicht zu dass sie
dafür kein friedhelm farthmann klein
franz müntefering kein irgendwas nein
die brauchen auch schon so typen die
sagen was ich will das jetzt hier werden
so ein bisschen schröder und auf den
namen noch sagen also so ein bisschen
schröder tut der partei immer auch ganz
gut einer muss deutlich machen dass man
auch ich will das jetzt werden und ich
weiß warum ich das werden will und ich
kann das auch diese attitüde war glaube
ich nicht erkennbar und die
sozialdemokraten in nordrhein westfalen
ist einfach so aber herr lohse werden
dass nicht erkennbar ist wie kann jemand
ministerpräsident werden da hab ich habe
ja auch gesagt die wette würde ich eher
aus schlagen also ich sehe das nicht als
sehr wahrscheinlich an aber es gibt wie
gesagt ein modell gerade natürlich bei
einer fdp die wahrscheinlich bereit ist
die originellsten sachen mitzumachen
wenn sie in einer ampel dabei wäre denn
ansonsten ist sie eine 5,6 oder was auch
immer sieben
position in einem land aus dem jahr fast
das gesamte bundespolitisch
spitzenpersonal kommt also der
vorsitzende der bundesfinanzminister gut
ist eine person der generalsekretär der
partei zwei von vier ministern der
fraktionschef der fraktionschef kommt
aus niedersachsen aber irgendwann kommt
der erste parlamentarische
geschäftsführer schon wieder
im grunde genommen ist diese partei wenn
sie in nordrhein westfalen nur noch 5,6
prozent auf 101 kommen wird nein aber
ich meine das ist ja die bildung einer
da könnte man zu greifen und sagen na ja
also die machen alles mit oder fast
alles mit diesen kleinen als die fdp
würde gerne noch mal ganz kurz bei der
spd bleiben herr christoph wenn ich ein
klingen weil heute abend gehört habe
dann war das ein sehr klares
klar man könnte fast sagen auftrag aber
zumindest eine sehr klare richtung dass
er gesagt hat also natürlich muss die
spd den ministerpräsidenten stellen
das eigentlich ganz so sagt man ja immer
der bund hält sich raus aus dem was im
land passiert aber ist das jetzt mal
eine klare alles
nochmals da die etwas passieren die spd
steht jetzt auch im bund nicht so
richtig toll da also man kann nicht
sagen das ist jetzt also dass die
performance im bund so großartig werden
warum man sich übrigens dadurch heilen
dass man mit einem jahr quasi
wahlverlierer dem minister für sie also
erstmal ist ja nicht natürlich dass er
gut start die das wird ja ist auch nicht
natürlich dass der bundesverfassung auf
jetzt machen hat thomas jetzt wird
ministerpräsident auch wenn du verloren
hast egal was wir vorher im bund gesagt
haben zweiter sieger verlierer und wo
ist jetzt egal wir essen die worte auf
du musst das trotzdem machen nein das
ist alles nicht nochmals als sich
natürlich aber es ist natürlich so dass
die spd bei der performance in der
bundesregierung und angesichts der
performance von habeck und baerbock
dringend sagen wir mal so ihre macht von
unten sichern muss die brauchte lauter
leute die ihr helfen im bund das
durchzusetzen was sie durchsetzen will
denn gucken wir uns auch an also berbalk
und habe die performance liebe dieses
wort die performance art und weise dass
die leute sagen mein job die neue straße
wieder gab die aber vielleicht nicht
doch die bessere kanzlerin gewesen also
der politik erklären dass er daran dass
olaf scholz nicht notwendigerweise als
politik erkläre aufgefallen ist das war
jetzt ironie er ist nicht als politik
erkläre aufgefallen aber habe kann es
die erklären die schlimmsten sachen kann
der direkten support
zur spd was hätten wir denn anstelle des
generalsekretärs und des
spd-bundesvorsitzenden gemacht in so
einer situation dass man den rasen sagen
nur einem land entschieden werden er
aber einen guten start i die man ja
schon an seiner ersten stellungnahme mit
glückwunsch an die anderen merken konnte
er braucht jetzt ganz dringend eine ganz
große batterie packung auf dem rücken
damit der losläuft und das haben die
beiden glaube ich heute gemacht weil sie
sagten okay die chance ist minimal
aber sie ist nicht gleich null und
märkten schon dass ihr coach ist ein
bisschen wackelig war deswegen da ein
wahnsinn sozusagen ersten stellungnahme
nach schließung der wahllokale ist ja
eigentlich auch furchtbar ist oder ich
meine du musst den mann dann zum jagen
tragen also an scheiße gesagt passt mal
auf noch ist so wie
wir wollen mit den reden und ajax hatte
er hat sich glückwunsch muss man
anerkennen und so und dann musste ich
sag ja da muss ein klimaabkommen seien
es dort aber ja es deswegen wird
vielleicht klappen aber ich verstecke du
hast du weißt nicht wir müssen wir sind
ja zu den grünen kommen denn wir das
ergebnis uns anschauen verdreifachung
des ergebnis bei den grünen will sich da
eine partei
gegen die ampel emanzipieren das heißt
will sich die freuen sich erst mal dass
er die vielen stimmen haben also das
waren ja erst mal was da heute passiert
ist waren die wähler und die grünen
stehen ja schon im bund recht stabil da
innerhalb dieser ampel das haben wir
jetzt mehrfach angesprochen die werden
natürlich ihnen welche regierungen
nordrhein westfalen selbst wenn es ein
schwarz grünes bündnis gibt werden sie
auch sehr gut dastehen sehr stark
dastehen das ist das was wir überall im
moment erleben die werden getragen von
einer breiten wählerschaft übrigens über
weitere altersstufen ja auch also das
ist ja keine partei die nur junge oder
es ist ja längst vorbei meinte heute
werden die 50 60 jährigen die irgendwie
als das erste mal zur wahl gehen wird
und sieht man sich die grünen ja auch
schon gewesen die jungen wellen andere
grüne das sind ja nicht mehr die alten
die sich nicht mehr die ideologen
sondern das sind pragmatischere leute da
fährt ein wirtschaftsminister der grünen
wohin noch einmal genau nach katar zum
gas kaufen geht also diese partei
die diese dann auch noch kommen
irgendwann durch afrika ist ja nicht so
viel öl deckt eine reifenpanne ab von
leuten die sehr pragmatisch sind haben
wir ein sonderparteitag wegen katar
wegen waffenexporten haben wir nicht
mehr und keine keine farbbeutel die
irgendwie so wollen dass es kein breit
inzwischen also jetzt können wir wieder
streiten was ist eine volkspartei und
die grünen haben auch schlechtere
ergebnis in letzter zeit gehabt aber
18 prozent ist zumindest mal so dass
manche von den partei das war guido
westerwelles wunsch
na ja also ich habe gerade gehört viele
die die grünen abdecken so zu sagen oder
viele ansprechen damit vielleicht sogar
auf dem weg zur volkspartei aber
gerade eben habe doch gesagt dass viele
themen auf landesthemen waren aber wenn
man sich die grünen anschaut dann ist es
doch vor allen dingen der effekt aus dem
bund der die grünen halten also neulich
hat der präsident ich glaube das ist das
heißt so dieses amt der präsident des
verbandes der chemischen industrie hat
auf dem parteitag der grünen für die
grünen geworben das ist ein recht
ungewöhnlicher vorgang und alle sind
zufrieden das kommt ja noch hinzu mit
einer spitzenkandidatin mona neubauer
die erreicht die herzen erreicht die
köpfe und zwar eben auch der
bürgerlichen
insofern ist für die grünen tatsächlich
eine win-win-situation auch hendrik wüst
muss trotz des wahlergebnisses und trotz
des relativen sieges muss den grünen so
viel anbieten damit die über die hürde
kommen weil ja die meisten in dem
landesverband immer noch so genannt
links sind die wollen gar nicht mit der
cdu regieren also nicht so richtig gerne
lieber mit den anderen so wenn das wahr
ist dann können die sich komfortabel
zurückgehen dann könnte jetzt monat
katalog machen da steht dann drinnen das
und das und das wollen wir jetzt alles
erreichen und über hendrik wüst im
zweifelsfall ja
aber wenn wir uns das anschauen das mona
neubaur eben vor allen dingen auf den
bürgerlichen klientel durchaus
angesprochen hat in der wirtschaft
unterwegs war und dort politik gemacht
hat sind die nicht extrem enttäuscht
wenn es auf einmal keine koalition mit
schwarz-grünen die
produzenten auch den zahlen zu erwarten
wäre mutig ja also der teil der
bürgerlichen wählerschaft der irgendwie
vielleicht nicht selber grün wählt aber
das auch nicht weiter verwerflich findet
oder grün wer kinder hat oder kinder die
grünen wäre eltern haben die werden das
wahrscheinlich schon so sehen weil das
ja immer auch so ein bisschen so lang
wir mal im liberalen bürgertums und
sehnsucht projekt war mal richtig
schwarz grünen wir sehen das in hessen
das ja im ruf steht eine erzkonservative
cdu zumindest mal gehabt zu haben geht
das wie lange jetzt schon ganz ruhig und
still mit schwarz grün ein
offenbar gutes modell man kann das auch
garnieren irgendwie mit mit herrn
kubicki das sehen wir in kiel das ist
angeblich sauer oder sagte umgekehrt
also aber das also dass schwarz und
grüne miteinander regieren und dabei ein
ziemlich breiten teil sozusagen der
bürgerlichen wählerschaft abdecken
vielleicht sogar noch weiter jetzt was
völlig märz gibt dass man sagt also da
haben wir wirklich alles dabei von von
freiheit ist future bis bis zu friedrich
merz das macht schwarz grün natürlich
relativ
attraktiv also das muss man dann auch
schon begründen das nicht zu machen die
hätten im landtag einen sehr weiß ich
nicht 12 13 14 stimmen vorsprung da kann
auch mal einer irgendwie bisschen von
der fahne gehen usw also das wäre im
grunde genommen so
politikwissenschaft ein seminar
wahrscheinlich die erste ja es ist
üblich wenn wir jetzt mal an nehmen es
gibt tatsächlich ein schwarz grünes
bündnis und hören herrn kriegen weil der
ja nun jetzt schon ordentlich wetter hat
das natürlich wieder was anderes haben
will tut er das auch deshalb weil er
vielleicht im hinterkopf hatten wenn das
auch gut funktioniert vielleicht färbt
ab auf den bund und dann gibt es
irgendwann jamaika die frage dafür dafür
gibt es ja sogar eine mehrheit in frage
zu stellen heisst sie zu beantworten
es geht darum dass die grünen immer
stärker werden es geht schon lange nicht
mehr nur um jamaika und immer cdu
bekommt immer auf die cdu nein wir haben
soeben sondern hinter gab die grünen
sind bei in nordrhein westfalen über 18
prozent diesen dem bund würde ich jetzt
mal schätzen 25 26 sind jetzt würde
jetzt gewählt über der spd die würden
jetzt den bundeskanzler die
bundeskanzlerin stellen das ist das
thema natürlich musste irgendwie ober
sticht unter die müssen versuchen immer
noch der koch zu bleiben das ist eine
ganz heikle situation für die spd die
haben bis jetzt nach der bundestagswahl
nicht beweisen können dass das nicht ein
ausreißer waren die aval ein ausreißer
geschuldet den glücklichen umständen
okay also wie war das noch alte fritz da
ein grosser general braucht auch
fortunen das wird jetzt olaf scholz für
sich in anspruch nehmen können aber
tatsache ist die müssen von unten jetzt
aufwachsen und du musst die grünen klein
halten und dazu dient dann natürlich die
koalition und wenn die schwarz grün
machen in nordrhein westfalen und die
grünen kriegen das was sie wollen und
sind damit erfolgreich das kann nicht
passieren
du lieber gott das ist ja dann
tatsächlich eine ganz andere situation
und die streiten sie auch nicht also
deshalb weil klingbeil sorge hat dass
das im bund nicht mehr weiter
funktionieren könnte weil die grünen
sich zu stark emanzipieren es wird
schwarz-grün immer wahrscheinlicher wird
deshalb ein so starkes plädoyer für ein
album ich glaube das haben wir ja schon
gesprochen jeder wie jede große partei
die chance dazu hat will natürlich
nordrhein westfalen führen das ist klar
die ganzen in den parteien kommen die
größten glocke aus nrw in der
bundestagsfraktion kommen immer die
meisten aus nordrhein westfalen also da
willen hat will man möchte den
ministerpräsidenten stellen das finde
ich jetzt einen natürlichen reflex und
wenn auch immer noch eine kleine chance
besteht wie im fall klar die spd dann
will das natürlich die bundes partei
alle mal in einer situation wo es nicht
so richtig rund läuft im bund sind wir
ja nun nicht einem punkt wo die ampel
koalition im bund auseinander bricht
also da wo es ist schwierig aber
gleichzeitig sind wir in einer
kriegssituation also da würde ich mal
sagen das kann ich nicht erkennen dass
morgen jemand sagt der lindner sagt auch
kommen dann dann machen wir das jetzt
auch mit der fdp
mit der mit der cdu aber
dass das natürlich je nachdem wie sich
die dinge entwickeln in einem schreiben
zwei jahren eine rolle spielen kann
irgendwann zu sagen und man sieht es ja
die fdp fremdelt er mit rot und grün
meine die hauen wirklich ein ding ob das
im pflicht ist ob das freedom day ist ob
das hansa lieferung sind die haut ein
ding nach dem anderen gegen rot-grün
raus fdp
müssen wir jetzt also minus sieben
prozentpunkte ungefähr sag ich mal
gerade noch reingekommen ist wie es
jetzt aussieht mit etwas über fünf
langsam personal lindner hat es damals
geschafft da wieder reinzukommen ins
parlament
warum hat das nicht geschafft opposition
ist immer einfacher als regieren also
noch etwas sagen das hätte ganz anders
gemacht und lindner ist ein begabter
hochbegabter ein hochbegabter
oppositionspolitiker in düsseldorf das
ist die voraussetzung also der
amtierende landesvorsitzende ist ein
bisschen unter wert geschlagen würde ich
mal sagen ja den kennt keiner so wie man
christian lindner kennt außerdem
überlagert nochmal bei der fdp dass der
kollege lose gesagt das was sie im boden
tun überlagert auch schon viel das was
im land machen also dass die fdp das
wird ja auch nur in nordrhein westfalen
an kommen ständig neue schulden zustimmt
und da diese ganzen geschichten damit
finanziert die die kontrolleure sind ja
dass dann der bundesminister für verkehr
nicht so richtig erkennen weiß auf dem
ja alle gesetze
dollar mann der ist sortiert und das ist
prima aber dann kommt er und das ist in
heutiger zeit das ist so wie wenn the
day renate künast um das mal zu sagen
ganz früher da sagt er wie sollen ist
immer das essen fotografieren und das
dann auf insulin posten das kommt bei
den jungen leuten an die sache soll das
denn das potenziert das
interessanterweise das mag für uns jetzt
irgendwie ein bisschen fremd sein aber
nein es potenziert das gefühl das die
fdp eigentlich nicht das liefert wofür
sie gewählt worden ist von ihrer
klientel auch innerhalb der ampel und da
mögen die gut zusammenarbeiten die
achten ja auch drauf das ist ja durchaus
ein sehr gepflegter umgang miteinander
und dennoch ist es so und das über wirkt
dann das und dann kommen die auch noch
wie gesagt auch alle aus nordrhein
westfalen sollen ja wenn es sind unsere
leute und dann so noch dazu eben gesagt
schulpolitik und dann passiert eben das
was passiert der kandidat ist auch eben
nicht so bekannt wie christian lindner
war überlagert natürlich alles ja in
nordrhein-westfalen wer ist die
nordrhein-westfälische fdp würden viele
menschen gehen wir noch sagen ja das
klingt nach dem oder der vogel oder der
ich glaube also die meisten leute würden
sagen minden hat das ist für uns dann
auch eine führungsfrage wie kann man den
menschen die dann danach gekommen hätte
das ist eine tatsächliche team fragende
führungsfrage du musst dir ja du musst
in die chance geben sich zu entwickeln
und groß zu werden und dann komme ich in
meinen alten textbausteinen wieder die
fdp hat in der letzten zeit sehr sehr
viel für trouble gesorgt für mich ja
immer wieder in die schlagzeilen mit wir
müssen auch wenn er fast am ende sendung
sind müssen wir noch auf zwei parteien
schauen einmal die linke die linke sich
die frage ist berechtigt nach schleswig
holstein und jetzt auch noch
nordrhein-westfalen völlig
marginalisiert ist also im westen dann
gar keine rolle mehr spielt fragezeichen
und die afg die jetzt das zweite mal die
könnten ja nur eine richtung nämlich
nach oben mit ordentlichen verlusten zu
tun die hat ja einige eine serie von
verlusten aber natürlich nicht so
schlimm wie jetzt mit dem rausfallen in
schleswig-holstein ganz aus dem landtag
und heute zumindest mal so zwei drei
stündchen wo sie nicht wussten ob sie
vielleicht keinen sinn darin sie sehen
jetzt drin aber sie sagen wir mal am
mittleren nachmittag war das nicht so
ganz sicher ob es so kommen würde also
die tendenz geht durch in die andere
richtung sie haben im bund die rolle des
oppositionsführers
verloren an friedrich merz sie haben
sozusagen in ihrer giften gegen das
brüsseler europa und
die integration ihren ihren treuesten
gewährsmann verloren weil der nämlich
auf die idee gekommen ist die ukraine zu
überfallen also das war für die afg ein
riesen von immer mit putin untergehakt
also das ist sehr sehr schwierig dass
dafür die linksparteien natürlich was
putin an gibt genauso gut genauso zu
dass das sind im moment auch dinge wo
erhebliche wahlkampf und
werbemöglichkeiten einfach verloren
ich bedanke mich sehr herzlich für diese
lebhafte diskussion analyse und profunde
beiträge zur wahlanalyse in
nordrhein-westfalen wir bedanken uns
sehr herzlich bei ihnen für ihr
interesse und wünschen ihnen noch einen
schönen abend bei phoenix wie sehen in
der später bei den späten nachrichten um
23 uhr sind sie noch mal unsere späte
wahlsendung mit allen neuesten
entwicklungen und den neuesten zahlen
und ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
[Musik]
der grand canyon
eines der größte